before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos you
already know guys if you have watched
two or more of my videos and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
while you're at it sign up for our
memberships to be involved in the second
half of the livestream in the chat it's
going to be members only we also have
some exclusive behind-the-scenes content
on top of that guys we just launched a
facebook page so if you guys want to go
follow that it would really help get the
facebook page off the ground and we just
started streaming on twitch as well
occasionally on twitch i do do some
debates with some other people that are
on twitch so if you want to see that go
follow my twitch
and lastly um you put eddie's instagram
in the description right that is correct
okay if you guys want to come on the
show we have a official recruiter for
the show his name is eddie so his the
link to that is in the description if
you want to come on the show dm him and
while you're at it follow my instagram
it's just dot pearly things okay now
that i'm done with my plugs for the
night um today we have a lovely panel
so why don't we go around everyone say
your name your age your relationship
status where are you from and then any
social medias you want to plug why don't
you start so my name is sahela social
media and not relevant i'm single
ready
and i'm from north london
my name is ibrahim you can find me on
instagram under at ibzb
i'm single at the moment age 39 i also
have another instagram known as the
masculine advocate
hey guys i'm miriam i am 21 i am
currently in a relationship
um my instagram is at official merriam
and do follow up my podcast conscious
conversations on all social media
platforms
okay hello guys my name is thomas i am
29
um i do not use social media and
yeah i am single although
i play for the same team so we're not
in i don't know how i would factor into
this but solid okay okay
so um today's topic is we are talking
about submission is sex a duty
so um there was a viral video
um that was taking twitter by storm this
week cam newton's girlfriend went on
sham booty's platform do you guys
familiar with shambody
so she's very much into like equal
partnerships type of relationship and
cam newton's girlfriend i forgot her
name off the top of my head but she
basically was talking about how being
submissive is very important to her and
that's the founding part of their
relationship so we're going to react to
her viral clip that's on shambody's
instagram and her youtube channel so if
you want to pull it up that's the first
two links that we talked about
so
um
and then i'm going to show it to you
guys too
so let's see
the
i'm going to go to ish okay so
i'm just going to show you guys
so this is the first one
what does a submissive woman do for her
man everything
what does that mean you know like
packing his bag
unpacking his bag
um just making sure all the things that
he wants and i i pretty much read
so it's like if i know you
and i study you like i know how you are
in the morning i know how you are about
midday i know her man everything
what does that mean you know like
packing his bag
unpacking his bag
um just making sure all the things that
he wants and i i pretty much read his
mind so it's like if i know you
and i study you like i know how you are
in the morning morning i know how you
are about midday i know when you're in
this mood what you need like before you
can ever ask me for something i'm
already on it i mean
he's spoiled and you know when i talked
to my girlfriends about it i was like oh
how are you guys doing i'm just like
girl he's running i'm like he's spoiled
rotten like he's running but i love that
like i want him to be there i think my
biggest flex is how i treat my man and
i've been known to love people back to
health and sometimes it's very draining
but my love is my superpower and i used
to hate that about myself but now it's
like i'm just embracing it like that's
who i am like if i love you i can heal
you
it's your joy it is my joy you know i i
love to see him
you know what that means and that works
what does a submissive woman do for her
man
everything
what does that mean you know like
packing his bag
unpacking his bag
um just making sure all the things that
he wants and i i pretty much read his
mind
what does a submissive woman do for her
man
everything
what does that mean you know like
packing his bag
unpacking his bag um
just making sure all the things that he
wants and i i pretty much read his mind
so it's like if i know you
and i study you like i know how you are
in the morning i know how you are about
midday i know when you're in this mood
what you need like before you can ever
ask me for something i'm already on it i
mean
he's spoiled and you know when i talked
to my girlfriends about it i was like oh
how are you guys doing i'm just like
girl he's rotten i'm like he's spoiled
rotten like he's ryan but i love that
like i want him to be there i think my
biggest flex is how i treat my man and
i've been known to love people back to
health and sometimes it's very draining
but
my love is my superpower and i used to
hate that about myself but now it's like
i'm just embracing it like that's who i
am like if i love you i can heal you
it's your joy it is my joy you know i i
love to see him eating the meal that i
cooked i love seeing him sleep easy
every night like clockwork i scratch
this man's back to sleep
and i know when he's asleep because i
can tell when his breathing changes and
some people might think that's psychotic
but that's like i just know that's when
i'm like oh i can stop now but i find
joy in being your rest you know so know
what that means and that works for us
because
he wants what i have to offer what are
you getting from all that you're giving
what are you asking for in return
what does
lost in who
just in mainstream culture yes
you know why and i think it's because
men don't make women feel safe to be
that
some men will say oh women are too this
they're too that but it's like
actually you're just not giving me that
king-like energy that makes me want to
submit to you because i think all women
have that in them it's just except for
you you said it's not you you said it
you made it clear and it's not you
what is that
not the trans but i love that you know
that about yourself i do but it's so
funny because you're saying this and i'm
just like that's everything that i am
not
but i love that for you though
and i love this for you yeah
i do
and this is this is how we meet in the
middle
friends love is a friend
i'm gonna take you on a trip baby
we're back
okay
so um question for the panel
what is submission to you and is that
something that
you the ladies would do in a
relationship that you would require
i like i don't even know
i don't even insight as a compulsion i
don't know you just you just tell me
what that means
yeah for you so where do you start um
for me yeah submission is something that
will happen naturally okay and you feel
safe
when the dynamic is healthy so yeah
okay
so would you be okay with all the things
that she said in the video like
scratching you guys back back to sleep
at night packing his bags
yeah to some extent it depends on the
individual so everybody for me has
different needs and when you're in a
relationship you learn that person's
needs okay so when you understand what
your partner loves and what they
like then that's when you adapt it for
your relationship okay what about you
i would say that a lot of what she said
wasn't really submissive to be honest
it's meal of actually knowing the person
like knowing what to put in their bag
um even cooking a meal isn't relatively
submissive that's more nurturing
submissive for me is part of a holistic
feminine build up it's one of the
attributes of fame of being like
feminine and in that case scratching
your back i would say is feminine but
not so much submissive packing a bag in
itself as well isn't particularly
submissive submissive for me is knowing
that the man has the power to make the
decision even though he may sort of
consult you and discuss with you any
issues in your relationship and where
you might be going that he has the final
decision so she didn't say a lot about
submiss being submissive to me then
secondly she said that she'd be
conditionally submissive some people get
it some people don't but the fact of the
matter is someone's either feminine or
they're not really so in that case to me
it seems like she'd be conditionally
feminine and to be conditionally
feminine is a bit of a red flag to me
and on top of that as well i expect she
would expect a man to be
all the time masculine so i wouldn't say
there was much submissiveness and
there's a lot of nice things being said
which i would accept and take part in
and enjoy from a partner but not really
submissive so would you say it would
have been submissive if um cam newton
was the one that requested it
and then she's going along with what he
wants yeah and that would be accepting
his decision and saying okay i'm willing
to do that for you and i agree with what
you're saying yes okay what about you
i i agree i don't think what she was
speaking was necessarily submissive i
feel like naturally as women we have
this incline when a man is your
protector and you understand your man
you are the nurturer and the submission
is a part of that and it is just
something that naturally flows out
within your relationship don't forget
submission is tailored to the individual
so and it's not tailored to the female
it's tailored to how your your partner
is because their level of submission
might be completely different to
somebody else's relationship it's for me
it comes back down to
how comfortable and how protected and
how
stable your relationship is and how you
feel in that and then a woman's natural
incline to be nurturing within her
relationship is where her submission
falls
okay
just from the outside sort of looking in
i kind of agree with everything that she
said
and the reason being is she's saying
that um
you know maybe the things that she was
describing doesn't necessarily
constitute submission but i think she
was expressing that these are the things
that she does because she's in a
position where as a woman she feels like
her man is fulfilling his responsibility
she feels like this is the guy this is
the person that i'm here for this is the
one who takes all the boxes for me and
as a woman she wants to give herself to
him so that was her kind of expressing
that and i 100 agree with her when she
says that she doesn't just do that for
anybody because she can't just do that
for anybody you have to
when you're in a relationship you have
to discriminate
and the reason being is because you
can't allow any old tom dick and harry
to come into your life
the person that is for you is the one
you would submit to he doesn't have to
ask for it you will give yourself to him
because he takes your boxes and to me
that's what a relationship is it's it's
effort that is effortless you give
yourself to somebody because they are
the person who
kind of does it for you do you see what
i'm saying
and that's why when she was like i give
it to some people and not others i'm
like bang on you shouldn't give it to
anyone are you free for all
no you're not i hear what you're saying
there but in a relationship bro yeah she
should pick someone who isn't a tom dick
and harry so therefore the person she's
picked would be worthy of that
submission if she's picking tom dick and
harry's addition at 10 here 15 there
that's not really a good thing because
if you're naturally submissive and
feminine yeah and you're picking quality
men the actual men themselves
will appreciate that and take that on
board and may go the extra mile with you
but if you're like teasing out i might
give you a bit of this or you know it
could lead to the relationship having
negative effects yeah so i hear what
you're saying you're completely right
but i would argue that's what she's
doing precisely because she's
demonstrated that there's people i would
pick and there's people that i wouldn't
do you see what i'm saying i hear that
but um
the main point i'm trying to make is
that she's demonstrating that the
quality of being feminine can only be
given to the correct masculine
and i completely agree with that i
respect that yeah because i always hear
um on one hand guys will say well it's
conditionally feminine like we don't say
we're conditionally masculine yeah and
so i hear them when they say that but
the other hand it's like
masculinity is leadership and submission
is following that guy's leadership and
some some guys aren't competent enough
their girls want to follow them that's
correct definitely maybe she shouldn't
pick him well i she's not yeah
shaming she picked cam newton she's
girls
got a good one that's a pretty good pick
and i also just want to say i feel like
let's not forget that everybody
male female has masculine and female
energy like feminine energy and for me i
always say
certainty
is what makes you a leader
and i feel like that is what is a big
factor within masculine men or women
that are a bit more in touch with their
masculine nature like the whole alpha
the the foolishness that goes around all
the time
certainty is what breeds a leader well
it's the ability to make a decision
because indecisiveness is feminine
and it doesn't necessarily mean they
make the right decision all the time but
it's it's that you're you're going to
make a decision you're going to be
confident in that decision and then
whatever happens happens you'll deal
with it yeah yeah but a lot of men can't
even get to the point where they can
make a decision yeah yeah that's what's
separate and i think
for um
a woman to be behind that decision a
hundred percent is
am i in the mic yeah okay yeah yeah it's
paramount so if you're in a relationship
and that man is making a decision you
have to be behind it because if you're
not then it breaks your relationship
you know
a lot of women downplay their part
to play in the foundations of the
relationship so the guy is leading but
you are the secondary you know like
fault behind that so if you're going
left and he's going right then the
relationship's going to break and it
allows other people to kind of instigate
and infiltrate your relationship
and
when a man makes a decision you know he
might not be asking you for your opinion
on the matter being comfortable with
actually just listening and
reasoning with your partner without
actually saying to them or not you know
i don't agree this is what i think
sometimes you just have to listen and
allow a man to have his thought process
and be supportive of it because that
that support is more important than
you're actually at you actually putting
forth another idea of saying i don't
agree you know just feeling hurt so um
furthering this right
do you guys believe that sex is a duty
in a marriage
and that is part of submission so you
start
i don't see it as a duty because as i
was saying earlier like putting the word
duty
is assigning it like it's a job
and for me
in a relationship the sexual aspect is
natural and it happens and it flows and
if there is an issue there it should be
able to be resolved
um but i i don't know it depends on
who's looking at it to be honest well
but let's say you get married tomorrow
right you meet mr tall dark and handsome
boom you get your rang you're married
right you're you're gonna be married
hopefully right 50 years yeah you don't
think there's times where you're not
gonna maybe the sex part will fizzle out
just realistically even if you're very
sexually attracted to him yeah so so
when that happens do you think it's a
duty
no because there's more to the
relationship than sex
so when you have a relationship there's
so many facets that build that
relationship for women yeah so i'm gonna
i'm gonna ask guys
so so so i'm just curious would you
marry it would you marry
yes you know
would you would you guys marry a girl if
sex was not on the table
no not whatsoever not at all no
no no i'm not saying sex is not on a
table if you're in a you know you're
married and it starts to fizzle out
that's what i was kind of talking about
that sex is important don't get twisted
but all sexual and it's very important
well i think i think the issue is that a
lot of men get involved in sexless
marriages and i saw a stat that said um
over the age of like 60 it's 50 percent
or in sexless marriages
and so it's like guys will get married
thinking that they that sex is part of
the deal
and then it fizzles out after the kids
after the woman gets the the resources
and the legacy that she wants okay
and so that's that's why i bring it back
to the question is when those times come
and you don't want to do it do you think
it's a duty and that's part of
submission is having sex when he wants
to
um i guess so yeah because you want your
marriage to sustain so at some points
maybe you don't want to
but it is what it is like i don't know i
don't i don't i can't i can't see that
for myself so i don't
for me i don't see it i think i think we
need to also separate what a duty is and
what submission is because i personally
would say that sex
is a part of your duty within our
marriage because marriage contains
upkeep
and upkeep is different from a man to a
woman men
you know are more active x y and z not
to say that women aren't because i know
plenty women are but that is more of a
requirement for a man than it is a woman
but to say that it falls into the into
the puzzle of submission i think that is
tailored to the type of woman or the
type of man that is in that relationship
i think sex is something that definitely
within a marriage
is a duty on both ends because
you like you might have a couple where
the woman is much more sexually active
or whatever it may be in comparison to
the man and it is it's something that
has to go both ways why because when
you're in a marriage you've decided to
commit and that commitment takes upkeep
when people say oh um if you think love
is the only thing that's gonna keep your
marriage together then you're then you
have like a shock it's that sort of
maintenance and it's required
what do you guys think
well i would say basically it's pretty
much a duty right the word might not
sound nice i mean it's a duty but i'll
say another word which is a priority
there's some key priorities in a
relationship one of those being like
respect love trust and sex is one of
those as well
don't get me wrong it can come to a time
where a woman doesn't feel like it and
so forth and if that's the case then
okay you can get away with it here and
there but if it starts to grow into a
prolonged period of time where a man is
not getting the cookies over maybe three
months or two months even a month really
that's like pretty extreme unless
there's some medical things going on
it's pretty much a duty it's a priority
to maintain a relationship so he may not
like the sound of it but it's a duty
just as it's a man's duty to provide his
sort of masculine attributes towards the
relationships of providing and
protecting a woman does bring femininity
and part of that
is
sexuality what do you think
um well initially i was of the opinion
that
while
in concept it could be considered a duty
it might not be at the same time
and the reason why i say that's because
the word i think duty kind of implies
that it's something that is owed to
somebody and then that's where for me it
kind of gets a little bit into icky kind
of territory
but um at the same time hearing what the
others have said they might have changed
my mind a little bit and that's just
because
you know as you were saying as you were
saying as well it is
part of a relationship and you have
committed
committed yourselves to each other
effectively for life because that's what
it is there's an oath to stay together
and so if one person wants sex and the
other one's like no what are you gonna
do when it gets to years down the road
sort of thing
so
i can definitely understand in that in
that regard but then what i would
probably replace the word duty with is
commitment
if just because it might sound a little
bit more pc
i don't know if that's the right thing
it just sounds a bit better but when you
say duty it kind of almost feels as if
if somebody was to you know say
no or somebody came up to you and said
you have to have sex with me it's your
duty just imagine being that person on
that receiving end you're just kind of
like oh that's a bit
kind of well i think i mean i think the
point is it shouldn't get to that
like as women if you're truly submissive
like like the guy should get especially
if if he's bringing like his time
attention and resources to the table
like yeah like i'm sure cam newton is
paying all of the bills do you think
that man deserves sex on demand fair
fair
that is true it's true it's like if i've
even had discussions with my friend then
they'll be like
oh you know um
if you're
um let's say in a in a situation where
you're you're you're going out and then
they pay
all like let's say hypothetical
date
you're going out oh i've gone out i'm on
a date they've paid for all the food and
all the you know all the building stuff
and now we're gonna go
um
home and you know oh i'm not gonna give
him sex not necessarily like it has to
be at that point in time but just
imagine like
and i'm just saying like
once you accepted his money you kind of
sealed that position of owing him
something not like you happens a lot bro
no no not like i'm not saying that it's
something that you should give up freely
but i'm saying once you ex start
accepting
stuff and taking from a person because
what girls you're taking what girls
investment in you what girls do is they
they go on dates with guys they're only
half attracted to or kind of attracted
to
and they waste that man's time attention
and resources whether it's conscious or
unconscious because if a girl is really
attracted to you it's going to be
incredibly hard for her to sit like to
to not have sex and that's like because
but a lot of times girls will go on
dates or like foodie calls
but i wanna i also just wanna touch on
the reason why i said i disagree is
because i feel like when you're dating
someone
nothing is obligated we can go on a date
and i can pay for the whole meal and do
you know what i mean oh no absolutely
absolutely when you're in a relationship
that's when the rules change no no
you're 100 correct i was just kind of
trying to use it as an example is the
idea of explain accepting something from
someone you're kind of allowing them to
invest in you right and then to just cut
them off it's kind of deep yeah yeah so
imagine
it being a full-blown marriage and
you're like nope
do you see what i'm saying
when you get into a relationship that a
lot of this is laid out on the table
because you can't have
like
all these expectations in your head and
not voice them and then when something
happens or like for example if if a man
expects regular sex he needs to voice
that to his woman and vice versa because
if they now have a disagreement and you
know as a man that her retaliation is to
withhold sex
you can't not come and be mad at her
because you haven't expressed that that
is a requirement for you
so like this is also another thing that
communication is very very key when
you're going to get into a relationship
or a marriage or whatever you need to
list what is required i would agree with
you yeah but i would say this though
there's a synergy between masculinity
and femininity they work together well
even sexual that sexual attraction when
two people really fancy each other on a
carnal level it's very hard for them to
withhold sex from each other so if
you've got to that point where she's
lost that for you or maybe you've lost
that for her maybe that relationship is
coming to an end so as i say like it
shouldn't go a long prolonged period of
time but um it is pretty much a duty
even though the word might not sound
right to some of them it is what it is
bro yeah can i just quickly add i was
gonna say just to add to miriam's point
yeah
sex is a form of appreciation to a lot
of men and when you don't show
appreciation yeah
you're you're teetering on on a fin
you're teaching on thin ice
in a relationship if there's women ready
to throw sex at your man and you're not
you're withholding sex then
for me
in that respect you're you're pushing
him away do you get what i mean so for
me it's a
a way to show appreciation
actually that was one of my that was
actually going to be one of my questions
if you're withholding sex can you be mad
if he cheats
hell no hell
no
yes and no okay why because i feel like
if a woman's going to put herself in
that position expect the worst she
understands because you've now decided
to withhold your
withhold your sexual interaction with
your partner but
me i did not come and force you to go
and do x y and z and step out on your
relationship or your marriage a man
needs to also have a level of
accountability yeah i could have been
the catalyst i could have been what i've
pushed you in that direction but also if
you love your misses you would sit down
and have a serious convo with that
there's a risk that's not that's not
true though because i feel like no no
but it's not because sex because again
sex is different for men and for women
men i've heard guys say on my show that
you know she was better than my hand
and
[Music]
and so and so it's like a guy it's just
like an instinct and maybe in his head
he loves his wife but if it doesn't if
she doesn't know it doesn't hurt her
and it has any and he knows deep down
like it has nothing to do with her i'm
not saying it's okay
but it's kind of like a lot of girls
will put their husbands in that
situation yeah like even if you don't
have even if you don't want to have sex
like your mouth can do something yeah
your woman is the catalyst because
you're foolish if you're going to do
that as a woman one thing i'd like to
add though is that the reason why they
cheat and keep it secret is due to the
fact that if the relationship's going
downhill she's withholding sex but if
they're married he's got a lot to lose
if he just says yep i'm walking out now
but there goes half your money there
goes maybe your kid's not being seen
there goes a big fallout between you and
this lady and now you're gonna suffer so
if you just do it on the slide get
yourself some extra curricular panani
basically they're doing it on the slide
due to the fact that repercussions of
telling you might even be more severe
you see i didn't consider that but
that's actually kind of true so you want
to have your cake and eat it too
not me in particular because i don't
believe in cheating if it came to that
i'm letting their bite hit the road
well it's not necessarily they want
their cake and eaten too it's just the
consequences for divorce is a lot higher
for men so in the u.s it's if a man gets
divorced and he has let's say two kids
by the woman his he loses 25
per child after taxes so your
discretionary income
and he owes that girl child support for
18 years exactly so so imagine imagine
you know making taking home 2 000 a
month and you have to give 1 000 a month
to your ex-wife for existing for 18
years and so when you're thinking about
cheating right and like now you're in a
sexless marriage
and maybe it's been a year maybe it's
been two years like it's
you could say hey i'm gonna cheat if you
don't give me sex but then she could
divorce your ass
so it's kind of like damned if you do
damned if
don't on a hard place
the concept of you
i feel like a man would know that is
like that is the potential thing that
could happen well well i i don't i don't
think most men know that they're going
to be in sexless marriages
i think that comes later
you can't predict that but i'm saying if
i'm like if a man goes out and cheats
and
knows that his
that this could be the potential
backlash from your wife that she will
leave you and whatever it may be you
know that that's a risk that you've
taken
right he does know what's at risk yeah
but it's it's like the other risk is to
demand sex from his wife and then he
could lose half his [ __ ] so from a guy's
point of view if there's just one random
girl that is never going to find his
wife and it's a one-time thing he
doesn't care about her he just hasn't
had sex in a year
and then like to them
it's just like the risk the reward
outweighs the risk because he doesn't
think she'll find out it's true to be
honest i would say that
you're definitely right in that respect
however
and not to kind of you know crap on men
so to speak because i
can completely understand from you know
those circumstances but i would say it's
always best to just encourage people to
do the right thing anyway if you really
really had a problem you know with your
wife and discussions weren't working it
would probably be better for you to
maybe discuss taking a break maybe even
split up now granted the woman's um
behavior in this scenario was she kind
of set up the
you know the whole kind of chain of
events that was following and makes her
man you know want to leave but
being the voice of reason we just like
encourage men to do the right see and i
do i don't agree with cheating but i
just
i'm thinking
i'm just saying
i'm cheap yeah okay i really i don't
like spending money why do i send money
get issue camera
[Laughter]
um
but but like i'm thinking if i if i had
the option of this conversation but i
know if she has this comp like me
because he knows his wife right he knows
that she's probably gonna leave if he
says this to her
so i'm thinking 50 of my income for 18
years after taxes
that's so much money
that's the number one way nba players go
broke is they get the wrong girl
pregnant so i can ask you a question so
in american law does it always default
the kids to the mother or is there kind
of like an investigation 80 percent
competency
the mom has to the courts are heavily
skewed against men yeah so
the mom has to like half it up big time
in order for to get to to not have
the kids so i want to say it's 80 of the
time
that she wins yeah it's pretty much the
same in the uk as well bro kind of rough
unfortunately and i believe it yeah and
child support here is around 20
or 18 i think 18
so it's not it's not as crazy as the us
the u.s laws but it's still enough that
i've seen a lot judge judy i know
but and that's and that's why you see
girls stealing nba players condoms
they're because
yeah that was actually kind of
outrageous because their their incent
the way the laws are now it's it's
incentivizing women to get a kid off of
a rich guy
because even even i think here it's
16 or 19 something let's go with 16
though if a guy's making 200 000 a year
that's still a big that's a that's a
whole income for me it is that's that's
wage i think it goes to 25 if they got
multiple kids so if they get two it can
go up to 25
in the uk
check me on that chat or wherever else
that's the relevant details but i
believe so wow and so it kind of that's
why it goes back to his sex of duty and
then
and it's hard because i the way i think
is there any way you could legally
protect that but i don't think you could
right
yeah and so it begs the question should
the courts even should the government
even be in marriage to begin with
exactly i think they should okay why the
reason why i think they should is
because the idea of let's say marriage
is not something that
like let's say for example when you look
at things like let's say faith and
religion you have a lot of people that
will talk about things like sanctity of
marriage and you know the government
shouldn't be involved however i'm of the
firm opinion that matt the concept of
marriage is not exclusive to religion in
fact i would argue in many places across
the world before religion even becomes a
thing
there is um concepts and ideas of you
know of marriage
and
you know if we're gonna say for example
live in a free society in a in in you
know in a world where you want your
spouse to have control over things like
if you're on your deathbed do they turn
off the life support or keep it on you
need that to be kind of recognized and
legalized you see what i'm saying
so for example if i've for whatever
reason inexplicably got married
and something happened to me i don't
know i got run over by by you know the
four nine on the high street
and you know i'm almost
couldn't they just ask you couldn't they
just ask every person i don't know who
the person because think about it like
this about your relatives your mother
your father your brother that's what i'm
saying when you want to marry someone
and form a family you don't want your is
and not to say you don't want but should
your
birth family like you know your mother
your father should they have
choice over your actual partner who
you've married and who you've created a
brand new friend you can just walk away
and take your stuff any day anyway bro
and turn your button off and take your
money so i'd rather have my mother do is
unconditionally
being her son that's unconditional that
woman who hasn't got unconditional love
for you
failed to provide the requirements she'd
be leaving you anyway now you're
completely let alone giving her the
power to shut your life down but you
you're completely right but you have to
kind of think of it like this if you're
the type of person who you know who you
get married and you actually create a
family that's your family no i agree
that's kind of the only reason why i
would say
in in terms of recognizing marriage it
should be recognized in the government
in terms of stuff like let's say things
that are more traditional you can do all
the bells and whistles go to church go
to the mosque go to synagogue or you
know if you're indian maybe in a temple
do you know what i'm saying but i'm
saying have the traditional aspects
couldn't they just have something on
your license with who who you want to be
your emergency contact or something like
if they had things like that which took
care of the whole legal side of it 100
percent why should
because it's like your next of kin
that's what it is bro pretty much i mean
i guess but wouldn't you have to the
power of attorney when someone dies and
so forth i used to work in a bank for
five years it can easily be done without
having any sort of marriage whatsoever
it could be your best buddy that you
grew up and went
nursery primary school could be whoever
you deem correct and someone who you
know is willing to actually maybe stand
by your side fight and die for you or
your mother or father who you know was
willing to die for you unconditionally
the fact of the matter is this person
even though your family does become your
family they still shouldn't have that
authority i don't believe but i can see
why people do it if they're in a perfect
harmonic synergistic masculine feminine
relationship then yeah maybe it can work
but in general hit that prenup bro and
have your one of your family members
so you would want one in your partner so
yeah what i was just talking about yeah
that's what you'd hopefully have so if
that was the case i see the argument for
it but to be honest how many marriages
end up in divorce anyway well and the
problem is a lot of girls change once
they get the ring
and guys will say this like oh in the
honeymoon phase she was the best
girlfriend ever
can you argue that both ways i was going
to say a lot of men as well they'll give
you right right but we don't have the
risk they do yeah you don't listen
so yeah so i mean it with us it's like
we don't we don't run the risk but they
they we we can get a check out of it
but then if it goes wrong and it's the
wrong person she can take half your [ __ ]
that's true that's why you've heard it's
cheaper to keep her it's true granted i
would probably argue if you know if kids
weren't factored into it it might be
more fair and the only reason why i was
i'm saying that is because it could
easily work the other way what do you
mean what i'm saying for example let's
say you were in a relationship where
the um wife was somehow making more
money than the husband their assets are
all shared if they were to split up she
would equally lose half of her [ __ ] not
particularly the courts favor men
i don't know generally speaking no sorry
women women i know what you mean
generally speaking you know
the courts do but i'm just kind of
saying where if it was somehow skewed on
the other end it would apply in the same
way if they were to divorce the only
time it generally doesn't is when
children are factored into it well i
don't understand why child support
begins like i don't understand why child
support is there to begin with like why
are you entitled to someone's money
why do you deserve it you can get a job
i work yeah i feel like child support
assumes that the father is not going to
be present and competent yeah
and that's not fair i was going to say
that and there's many ways to support
children and the last way is in my
opinion is financially so yeah i agree
with you on that point i i think that
child support is a very business-like
transaction like process that supports
women kind of
you know benefiting financially while
still they're not in the relationship
anymore and because the way that the
british government works there's no kind
of foundation
around okay what can i spend this on is
there a system where this can only be
used on children's swings or you know
what i mean
i'm just a big believer and you made
your bed lie in it so if you're if
you're worried if you're worried he's
not going to stick around maybe you
should have picked a better guy because
i don't i don't i don't find that most
women that are in these situations had
zero red flags and zero warning signs
and he just magically switched one day
you either knew he was going to be a
good father and a good husband yeah and
and
yeah
and he is and if that's the case and it
doesn't work out he will likely take
care of his kids anyway or you're dating
pookie and ray-ray
and you're one you're and you're shocked
that they're not fathers and husbands i
was going to say that this is the
problem as i said you said on the last
show
the thing with women and relationships
is when the man departs or leaves the
relationship they still want to have
control and this is not control over
just the finances but control over him
his emotions if there's children
involved that is a bargaining chip
having the financial means to control a
man's uh
rent the way he pays his bills the way
he operates in his daily life without
even having contact with him i think
it's very very
divisive speaking to them oh
oh it's right next to my face
okay
and then um
but
it's
it's designed in a way like he said that
the man does lose
a lot of women because they don't have
the man they want to control him outside
of having a relationship just say
something about this whole the man loses
yeah i understand like when you divorce
a woman you're losing fifty percent x y
and z
this might be a bit outlandish but in my
eyes
you're a man you are provider do you
understand so if you notice a part of
your risk why why are you so scared of
this risk you're gonna go off anyways
and you're gonna provide for yourself
because before you got into this
marriage you made sure that you could
provide for yourself and your partner
and your future family so for the fact
that like leaving this woman or divorced
in this woman now you're thinking oh 50
is gone and i have to pay x y and z this
is a part of something that is innately
within you it is to provide yeah but so
for your family is no longer your family
yeah provide for the kids not some woman
has walked out broken up the family
house and this is where they're going
and now it's talking about giving me
half of your income that income should
go directly to the children her income
should go directly to the children they
can live a separate life hopefully be
amicable and respectable but most most
guys are cool with with providing for
their kids what they don't need is the
government telling them that they have
to yeah and putting a gun to their head
and sending them to prison if they don't
i agree with that that's why i said it's
more of like within the man's character
and not the legal side but then but then
it goes back to like it's on us it's on
us to pick the guy yeah and so and so i
think a lot of times women are always
bailed out for our bad decisions
so so we can we can pick the wrong guy
right have a kid by him and the
government pays us out for being a
single mom
and we get we get better housing because
we're a single mom so bailed out for
that decision then on top of that we're
entitled to his income so we get bailed
out again instead of saying hey
pick better guys you made your bed lie
in it you need to figure it out it's not
the government's job and it's not his
job to figure it out
we may need to take some accountability
bro some accountability needs to be
taken because women have the power
women have the power they're the ones
that decide who has sex there's no man
that can take sex from a woman without
her permission so in that case she has
got the power the children that are
being birthed is down to that woman
because if the man wants the child and
the lady says i'm sorry mate um you know
i don't really feel up for it i'm going
to finish off my degree in all good
power to her but you're not having that
child so the woman has the power in that
case so she has to take a bit of
accountability a responsibility for who
she's sleeping within a type of
character of that man and his masculine
traits or any red flags she might have
picked up not to sleep with him to end
up in a situation in the first place and
if a girl and if a girl and if a girl
gets pregnant it's a choice
she chose to do that because because no
it really is because we have okay you're
telling me you had no idea you could get
pregnant when you could track your cycle
you could be abstinent you could choose
not to have sex on top of that you could
you have plan b the morning after pill
on top of that you have abortion if you
do get pregnant on top of that you have
adoption if you if you get pregnant you
want to have give birth to the baby and
give it up on top of that you also have
iud which is 99.5
effective you also have birth control
which is also around 99
effective on top of that you can require
the men that you sleep with where
condoms which is also
like you you have option option option
option option option option and then
you're gonna say and then then you're
gonna set then you're gonna say
oh boohoo i'm pregnant what the [ __ ]
okay i i completely agree
but let's not sit here and act like
every woman a has this knowledge
a has access to all these things has
been taught all these things that women
don't go without sexual desire
that women aren't a bit ditzy every
there's we're not all just okay this is
2022 they know these things man there's
a condom from anywhere condoms free in
these family planning places a lot of
people aren't talking about
the health and sex okay so if if that's
true then why is it that the majority of
abortions are from women that make 47
000 or more a year one out of three
women have had them where only eight
percent of women below the poverty line
have had an abortion no no i so i said
to you i agree to what you're saying a
lot of women would make certain but what
i'm saying i'm saying the data does not
indicate that it is an education issue
exactly because it's the most educated
women that are getting abortions it is
the most high the highest earning women
that are getting abortion so to me that
indicates that it is a lack of
responsibility and poor choices
rather rather than education and also
the average age of first abortion is
going up it's not the majority of
abortions are girls in their late 20s
so so it's so it's to me if you're if
you're 25 and you don't know how to use
a condom i think you have bigger
problems
even i think 21 if you don't like
honestly honestly i'm kind of a bit on
the fence with this one and the reason
why i say that is because while you know
women do have
pretty much
full autonomy over their body that you
could argue about my body my choice yeah
i mean you can argue about that now
because not quite in america let's say
but um
you know
they should they would be able to detect
you know things that you know yeah
they're pregnant yeah i've tracked my
cycles as you said all all that womanly
stuff
but
at the same time i think it's a little
bit not fair to kind of kind of put
everything in the woman's boat to say
that you know you have to watch the guy
you sleep with
i would also argue to the men you have
to watch
the and and not to be you know a bit
crude you have to watch the
table
the person you dive into so
so here's the problem with that a guy
can do everything right outside of
abstinence he can do everything right
and the girl can still steal the condom
there's entire reddit threads of women
talking there's entire reddit there's
entire reddit threads of women talking
about how they want to trap a man yeah
so can i just say something is this is
the thing a woman will not get pregnant
by a man she does not want to get
pregnant yes
and you know as a woman
i can like a man i can sleep with a man
and i know i'm not gonna have a child
with this man
but that's it's
real life women know when they're lying
with a certain man i want this man's
child regardless if he wants it or not
regardless of uh protection and uh
birth control and whatever else like you
can track your period and it actually
works it's a it works well and that's
and that's what i'm saying when i say
it's a choice like you chose to get
pregnant it wasn't it was a decision
because you had
a b c d e f g like yeah no you're right
yeah
can i just add as well you know when you
look at certain court cases paternity
cases
when you see the women speaking those
the cases themselves it's all
emotionally driven by what the man did
what them
they when they had the children the
child whatever they knew they wanted the
children they knew they wanted those ch
the child right so because sorry takati
but just because it didn't go on their
terms at that point it became an issue
so
continue right well and we that's what
i'm saying we always bail women out of
bad decisions it's it's always there's
always a fail-safe for women and we
don't have that for men that's why men
make up the majority of homeless people
and i think the reason why they do
that's because the law just kind of
assumes that oh women are nurturers you
have the kids you have the bulk of the
responsibility if you're with a guy and
he's you know you split up with him he
was your provider we're gonna make sure
he provides and then they just take
everything from him and i feel like the
law kind of just assumes that because it
can't be bothered to actually
investigate a situation properly
and each case is so different that's why
it goes back to when i like when i think
of sex being a duty because you get his
protection and provisioning that's the
exchange
if we're being honest that's what the
exchange is he gets he gets sex on
demand and you get his resources his
provisioning and his protection
everything's transactional
but i would also argue that you know
there's a lot of children sorry forgot
that all those who argue there's a lot
of other things that women might break
bringing to the table just i mean let's
say for this discussion sake we're just
assuming that the man is more of a
provider role and the woman's a more
stay-at-home nurturing sort of role
and
you know fair enough yeah if the if the
guy wants sex he's allowed to ask his
wife for that i think when we call it a
duty it is back to that word again it's
a little bit icky
granted yeah i was going to say that the
court system and the laws of the country
are still traditional but the society is
feminine is i'm sorry i'm feminist so in
that case like men will get charged more
women will get certain things but the
fact of the matter is if we are actually
living by this sort of feminist culture
where men and women are equal shouldn't
that come to the case with divorce as
well where it should be
rather than this sort of skewed old
traditional style which maybe was needed
for maybe 50 80 100 years ago but it's
not relevant anymore can i
just say yeah yeah back to what paul was
saying before
the reason i don't like the way that the
court system works is because it
depletes a man this is what i was going
to say before but it depletes the man
and expects him to still be able to
provide and that doesn't make sense how
can a man that's depleted actually
provides
and and for me especially when there's
you've got men who look after their
families extensively children i don't
know grandparents whatever that might be
it can be very very it's a fine thread
and we've spoken about this before
mental health well-being men being able
to express themselves freely and going
back to its point here with the feminine
society we consider women over
all men so their emotions the way they
feel about it like the word we're saying
is a bit icky
but it's about that's a feeling
it's a feeling it's not
you know the tangibility in that
it doesn't translate so we get nitpicky
about how we feel about something and
everybody here
everybody hears us we they hear us and
we say oh we don't like you know the
guys doing this and we don't like that
but i mean just like yeah and then it's
but it strips back on the fact that you
expect a man to be a provider then you
expect him to be a man but you're
stripping back on his masculinity
because i could also say is is it a duty
for a man to provide for his family like
what if he's being what if he's being a
bum and just refusing what if he's what
if he no but
but i'm saying i'm saying
i'm saying but most people wouldn't say
that sounds icky
right so if i said oh you'll come if i
said it's his duty to provide get a job
yeah i mean
and if i say if i say to a woman hey
it's your duty to have sex have like to
be honest that's easier than getting it
like then working 50 hours a week i mean
completely but i mean there's working in
this sex yeah but i mean it's it's not
to say like she just said if you're not
providing you're not having sex right
yeah so it's the same so if you're not
having sex the man ain't provided
is that nice
okay cool would you accept that this is
my finger
there's two things i want to say first
of all
the whole feminism stuff that you were
talking about this is why feminists
irritate me because you want to speak i
don't believe it's going to sound a bit
mad i don't believe in equality but i
believe in equity yeah okay i believe
that if if if
you're earning five pounds a day and
someone's earning 50 pounds a day and
they're giving you a five and you're
thinking that's gonna suffice that's not
how it works that's not like it doesn't
make sense because everybody's life is
very subjective and it's very different
so equity is one thing if women are out
here screaming equality equality
equality and then things happen and
they're going into courts now and
they're coming from a very emotional
standpoint which is closer to say their
nature and that is now their argument
you've basically gone against everything
we've just you've just protested against
right a and um what were we just
speaking about i just had a point um
well you basically said if he's not
providing he's not getting no sex and
then i said well if you spin it the
other way around if he's no sex and he's
not providing what do you think about
that let me tell you something here
most women
know what a man is i know how a man
should act but me like for example i'm
gonna use me forget everybody else i
know what a man is
but i will never go and step to man and
tell my mind how to be
do you understand i know i know how a
man is i know how certain things need to
be within a man but i could never come
and tell you you're not a man or like
this is what requires you to be a real
man
because i just feel like there's a
certain essence that needs to be
separated can i can i say something
about the difference there's equal
weight like you got an equal weight over
10 000 kgs of rocks and 10 000 kgs of
feathers they're equal weight but they
have different qualities that feathers
can be blown away in the wind but the
rocks is still the same weight but it
stands firm that's the difference
between the masculinity and femininity
they've got different attributes and
extremity to be synergistic and work
together so question what do you mean by
equity
so i believe that
if you see like for example say there's
a fence here
and
one person is six foot two and one
person is five foot and a quality would
be you get a box each and that would be
it and whoever if you get to see you get
to see and if you don't get to see you
don't get to see but you're equal
i believe in equity where if the six
foot two person needs one box and the
five-foot person needs three boxes for
them to spoof c that's equity for me so
so based on equity would you say that
women should be sleeping with more men
no but no but like let's sleep with the
short kings i think i think equity i
think meant anybody when it comes to sex
i think
each today no equity come on
let me tell you something okay if you
want to do what you want to do do what
you want to do five foot and broke i'm
gonna tell you the equity the reality
but look i know a lot of let me not even
say it like that but i
have
interacted with a lot of women that will
have sexual relationships with a mom
yeah but he's hard because his cataract
his game is amazing and they will stick
around and they will be on his air
mattress doing it all for two years
okay so so i'm gonna give you a couple
stats that might sway your view on this
so if you ask a hundred if you ask a
hundred percent of women what they want
in a guy they list twenty percent of men
women only swipe on between five to
15ish percent of men on dating apps that
one out of three men under 30 are
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year women are incredibly picky yes we
are but they have to be there's a
statistic that says um there's
certain qualities and i'm like this is
me very loosely reiterating it there's
qualities within a man that only 40 of
men actually possess but 80 of women
desire
so there's a there's a small bubble of
men that all these women are throwing
themselves at because they have all
these qualities and the risks are just
left but but what you said based on
equity we should be
more inclusive
to make it to make it even i was
referring to in terms of the legality of
things and in terms of the legalities
and stuff like that i don't believe that
like because we we were speaking about
the feminism and okay
i don't believe that should be can i
have an example of a law specifically
that would benefit like that supports
what you were talking about equity i
don't think there really is one
at the moment oh well that what you
would advocate for um
because i'm just trying to understand
what you're talking about when you say
that because there's no real life
situation where we're on boxes with the
facts
chart support child support yeah yeah
okay so how would you do it
um i um
i need to think about this because i
don't want to yeah
for starters we're not going to take the
dad for a ride yeah do you see what i'm
saying and let's say the mother might
have a bit to contribute herself they're
gonna they're gonna balance it to the
point where it makes sense for both
parties
so in the neighborhood in terms of maybe
income because a lot of i think a man
should be a or whoever whoever messed up
should be accountable and that would be
the catalyst to the child support
exactly and the whole arrangement woman
earns more than the man yeah and also it
wouldn't it wouldn't default women as a
custodial parent it would observe the
full situation
and it can reduce the amount that the
man ends up paying or whatever it may be
or it could just completely avoid the
woman
so if there's a huge income disparity
would you still advocate in the name of
equity that the other parent gets it
because what do you mean because again
like i'm just thinking of the boxes
example yeah and in like in that case
the the guy that was super short versus
the guy that was really tall one got one
box the other got three so when i'm
thinking in the court system if someone
makes three times the amount of money is
the other
would you then take from one to give to
the other
and then like in the name of equity and
within the relationship no no i mean the
relationship's done
so yeah so explain it to me so in in the
box situation that you gave me right
the short guy got more boxes in the name
of equity right yeah and so in this in
this case one one person makes three
times the amount the other person yes do
you take money from the person that
makes three times the amount and give it
to the other in the name of equity
i would say if the matt if the man she
it and and they divorced them that was
their reason and now he has to pay child
support if the woman earns three times
the amount i would rebuke the child
support
so so if the man cheats would you mean
rebuke then she doesn't have to pay
child support because he wouldn't have
to
he wouldn't have to because she earns
three times the amount i think it would
she have to pay him divorces would she
have to pay him no because she's not the
reason for their divorce
so but what about if it's do they just
divorce for no reason
then you split everything 50 50.
but i'm but i'm saying you can't split
everything 50 50 because they make three
times the amount as the other but i
think that that
the reason why i'm going to say that
changes within a marriage is because
when you come together you're unionized
you're two individuals that come
together so you know
before or like when you're married to
this person this is their income x y
right
if there's no real cause or it just
comes to a thing where you fizzle out
within your marriage and x y and z i
think
agree upon assets agree upon what she
wants what he wants make it out to it
for it to be even
and go your separate race and that
should be a personal thing i don't think
that should be something that so okay so
you would say
you would say that there shouldn't be
child support then
no that's not what i'm saying okay i'm
saying that
it's very circumstantial
if if if if you're say your ex partner
is on 25k a year
and you're on 100k
right and he
slept to somebody else i have now
divorced him as the wife mm-hmm i don't
but you don't know why he slept with
someone else like you could have not
been giving him sex personal matters
that's between you and your your partner
right so then shouldn't it not matter in
the divorce proceeding well
shouldn't it not matter in the first
divorce proceeding why you guys divorced
yeah it would be it wouldn't though it
would just be unless it's something that
you're saying you're saying it does
matter because you're saying if if he
slept with someone else then there's no
there's no child support even if the
girl makes more let me clear it up okay
yeah because y'all let's get into this
right now i'm just trying to understand
what you're saying no i hate you what
i'm saying is if my partner has now
cheated on me
and i have now fired filed for divorce
knowing that he owned he earns 20 25k a
year and i'm and i'm on 100k a year
first of all me as a woman i wouldn't
even want your money but i just believe
that it doesn't make sense to now come
and make the man pay
uh 18 25 whatever it may be child
support when he it was basically on
minimum wage what's the relevance of the
cheating then was he they left for him
why is it cheating that he usually could
just say she said she don't want to be
with him no more 100 but then just
divorce yes i'm saying so the cheating
is not really relevant so if the
cheating is not relevant nothing should
be that side of things shouldn't be
relevant it's not relevant financially
don't forget your person of emotions
your partner is a person of emotions i'm
not saying you can't get divorced but
i'm saying in court yeah like don't you
think in court when we're talking about
money what happened in the bedroom
should like stay out of court yeah why
is that right why does the judge need to
know this i think okay so so i'm saying
but like you were talking about equity
so
let's say the man makes three times what
the woman makes does he owe her any
money after like the divorce that's what
i'm asking
i would say for for they have kids yeah
i would say why
because
it's not just this woman that you
like you are now
if this woman say she has soul custody
or majority custody of the child for
example you provide for your kids that's
50 of you do you know what i mean it's
not like this woman who you know is not
in any way shape or form genetically
related to you right now but
it makes sense it just i don't i don't
agree because why because why is she
entitled to his money go get a job women
leave women women women leave 70 to 80
percent of the time and in when they're
college educated 90 so why why are we
incentivizing women to leave we're
giving you a reward so you leave and you
get you get a check yeah
as i work right and i work really hard
at what i do and if i if i married a guy
that made three times what i make like i
don't think even if i have kids by him
that he's i'm entitled to his money no
just but your kids are yeah right but so
so shouldn't he shouldn't he shouldn't
he have the freedom to spend like the
money on the kid most guys want so but
why does so but in the way that you're
talking about it now like you're saying
that she's entitled to his money i said
your kids are because your kids are
literally 50 right but child support she
gets so he
that's what i'm saying like shouldn't he
be able to spend the money
she shouldn't get it because that
doesn't make sense i think the only way
that this can actually make sense is if
the court actually has an impartial view
when it comes to deciding who takes
custody of the children because most of
the time as you know as we've said
before when a divorce happens they just
give the children to the mom they have
to actually investigate who's competent
and then the competent person gets to
have the children then they can decide
based on what a person let's say the
money that they make what kind of
contribution would be sensible to to be
put towards the care of the kids i mean
i think it should automatically be 50
50.
and then like i don't think there should
be an investigation unless there was
abuse
no but i feel like or drugs
yeah i feel like there's many reasons
why people can divorce but i think you
know as you said there are some
circumstances where i would say it does
call for investigation
um like let's say for example you said
abuse would you would you agree that
that's the exception rather than the
rule
how do you mean would you agree that in
most cases people aren't abusive
oh so so that's those cases
so in most cases it should just be 50
50. yeah but i would say
divorce the reason it's not 50 50 is
because money cannot be made if if it's
50 50 then the woman doesn't get any
money because it's 50 50. so there's no
money to take from that because the
court will say boom the dad has the
child 50 50 you have it have the child
50 50. so then you can't demand money
because you both equally have the
children absolutely you understand it's
a business
but that's what i mean when i say they
should establish sort of like competency
if both parents are deemed fine
then of course i mean what would be the
reason for child support you get them
half the time yeah
but the thing is is business like i said
before on this show
for men they pay into the system women
are more likely to get legal aid they're
more likely to get
provisions to support them in a court
case yeah men will take their finances
from their job or whatever and have to
pay to defend their side of the story so
it's a business for the courts and for
the women involved if the if the court
said boom everybody's got 50 50 there is
no court case yeah because that that is
the most valuable asset but one of the
things that you that you you what you
said that's actually kind of made me
think of something is that that kind of
whole system sort of destroys the whole
traditional notion of a stay-at-home
mother and a working father because if
the woman let's say divorce is a man
she's automatically in a position where
she's not making any money and then the
court's just going to take her side do
you see what i'm saying yeah but they're
probably going to help her why is she
though she divorces she gets 50 50.
she's got half the time to earn some
money bro just like the man's got
obviously let's say if she was in a more
traditional role it's almost as if the
whole situation kind of
like de-incentivizes
being traditional but because as soon as
she let's say leaves in a divorce she's
in a position where the courts will help
her with everything the the legal system
from going to court to
do you see what i'm saying and then it's
like men are like okay so you're saying
she's not capable or intellectual enough
or has no skills i'm saying get a good
job saying that the way the court
automatically treats providers
completely disincentivized as having a
traditional family structure having that
marriage because the man will lose his
stuff
okay yeah the man will lose his stuff
basically one thing pro can i just say
like they say this equality in equity if
he asks a woman do you want equality
with sex if you ask any like
clear-minded woman do you want to be as
we say in england a slag or a hole
they're saying no they don't want to go
sleeping around but if he asks a guy if
he wants to have his freedom to engage
with women it's like yeah i do actually
so these things sometimes don't relate
and most of the time these equities and
equalities they don't exist but they're
not yeah and this actually brings me up
to my next problem which i was actually
having discussion with my friend about
so
yeah literally i feel as if
especially when you go back let's say 50
60 maybe even 70 years ago there was a
lot of let's say in more western
societies where women and other
minorities were kind of
you might say oppressed or
kept in a position where they didn't
want they wanted to move on and evolve
from that
and wait depressed how are women
oppressed no not oppressed but i mean
like let's say for example oh you have
to be stay at home let's maybe more than
70 years women weren't allowed men had
to wait
man had to fight in wars we didn't have
no absolutely but i mean think of it as
in la having not not having the right to
vote or not having the right to most
people didn't have the right to vote
women didn't even want it i mean
actually like when you surveyed women
right but they didn't want it because
that like the you know freedom comes
with responsibility so if we got the
right to vote we have to be drafted yeah
i mean but that's what i'm saying but
it's not even just necessarily that
let's say you go back to a time where
they are um positions where
just for lack of a better term say they
were oppressed
the fact that women have been given
rights and there's nothing absolutely
wrong with that absolutely the fact that
it's created more rights more freedoms
more so and so it's kind of
created a type of tyranny because you
look at all these say for example
oppressed groups that have been given
who is tyranny the women now yeah and
not just women you kind of look at the
oppressed groups
and they're not just they're not content
they want more
they want more because they're not
satisfied with being given their rights
they're emotional they're angry they're
hurt they want revenge what's at the
expense of men yeah yeah they they're
emotional they're angry they're
tyrannical they want revenge i mean
imagine what's happened society has
facilitated women women say men are
trash constantly i hear that i hear that
all the time what if men said women are
[ __ ] would it be the same effect
well if that's that's the only time that
that anyone would pay attention
right but i'm saying i'm saying like
people freak out on social media
they do like whenever a guy says like
stop stop wiping horrors don't marry
horace like everyone freaks out yeah
they're not even saying they're bad
people they're just saying look yeah but
i mean it's kind of common sense it's
like saying don't date a murderer well
you wouldn't right right but i'm saying
i'm saying like men are trash like that
that's
accepted i just say the men are trash
comes from women who didn't grow up
being nurtured by fathers this is the
problem no it comes from them picking
bad men but check it if you okay your
mom
divorce your dad you're grabbing a
single parent household you had very
little interaction with your dad because
your mom stopped it from happening you
then go out make the same poor choices
you stop your you have children with
guys or a man you stop that child or
your children from seeing that man
because you've never experienced male
nurturing
you're now two generations down in your
family and nobody's had male nurturing
most of the women don't know how to
function with men in their household
they don't want to
and i for me i have i've been nurtured
by many men in my family and i know the
benefits of that there's different
competencies confidence and ability to
make choices and you you've had in you
know you have your dad in your life you
can make choices and have
straightforward logic
but that's fine like i i understand like
some not all girls had a dad to raise
them but i'm saying like women can't
take that out on men it shouldn't be
acceptable what my point is is if your
free generation is down in your family
and there are no men you don't no
grandfathers no uncles nothing so men
are trash because they're no use to you
in your family and for me like family is
the pinnacle of who you are before you
step out of your house but the way you
interact with people it's shaped by your
family so in
this the sense of court cases and
children family and equity equality
finances if you don't understand how
family dynamic is supposed to work and
you've never experienced that how can
you then apply that to your life mm-hmm
forget what i'm saying i would say
that's absolutely true but that you
could even maybe argue that the other
way around as well yeah but yeah because
there's a there's a generation of men
that weren't raised by wives either
and so they have a lot of like like
callous cold like mothers that raise
them and like they don't really have
that and that's the thing it still boils
back to the women it's men are trash so
even in that case the women don't know
how to nurture male children they don't
want to because and their whole
direction is their son is now their king
and all notice these these funny things
sun husbands
i'm gonna take a second to read super
chats really quick
um so guys as you know all super chats
are being
donated to get issue camera i know all
of y'all want to know what ish looks
like look like yes yes we do you're at
the edge of his you're at the edge of
your seat right he's a good looking guy
right guys we're trying we're trying to
see yeah
[Laughter]
sorry
anyways anyways so you guys send money
get issue camera
um also
um i've been trying to get to super
chats but the priority of the show is
the flow of the conversation so that is
first priority um i know it's
frustrating sometimes you guys send
super chats i can't read them
immediately if you send a 50 or 100
super chat
we will take priority to those and read
those first within 10 minutes i'm going
to watch the chat so if i see one that's
50 or 100 i'll make sure to ask the
question i'm sorry guys we just can't
prioritize everyone that's just the way
we're gonna do it so
overanalyze women fall in love with what
they hear men fall in love with what
they see that's why women wear makeup
and men lie
um
oh wait let me refresh this because i
think this is from the last show
let me refresh it real quick
okay yeah jake bannon um two dollar
super chat thank you stephen o'brien the
government gets a cut out of child
support that's an open conflict of
interest and flagrant corruption and it
and it's allowed because it benefits
women crazy um sibo and cube traditional
women don't get divorced hey pearl you
you me sarah and ish's new camera should
blow up only fans um i'm good on that um
sick lead the government makes money
from the man in most child custody cases
trevor lane 95
of scientists define life at the point
of concession concept conception but the
left is pro-science whatever that means
at least be consistent take
responsibility david brantley my ex-wife
cheated on her first husband no kids
when they divorced she negotiated for
money from his book deal and got two
hundred thousand dollars how is that
right
e30 that this is why men simply aren't
getting married xxx think they can take
your whole check ransom at the drop of a
hat xxx prioritizes themselves
brittany cormier she cannot give you an
example of equality because the sound
bite she thought she
she thought was great and right did not
give an example so she cannot parrot it
to you zest bodied by the short king's
equity if she wants equal outcomes for
for all then let's dole it out sister
has no idea what she's advocating for
brit cormier how many times alimony or
child support is reduced when the man is
laid off or has to take a lesser paying
job to stay in the area of his kids
companies move jobs but if he leaves the
state he gives up custody of his kids
utmost i'm curious pearl are you in the
uk yes we are why is everyone on your
show british because i'm in the uk
great content um vincent dolezyle girl
on the left is confused i feel sorry for
her boyfriend her misandry is showing
trevor lane i worked with a guy who got
sent to jail for not paying child
support problem is the child support was
over two-thirds of his paycheck that's
not right trucker 2019 when a woman can
just up and leave because of no fault
divorce it's the man's problem ob
classic
child support alimony and marriage
licenses exist because the courts get a
cut of what the what has to be paid it's
not all about money the government does
not care
um vincent
dolasat lyle
um bull on the left holds all of his
sims inside that nose ring he siffens it
out of the ring during discussions
brent cormier issue is
she will never go without sex because
she is a woman and she can get sex any
time she wants she does not have the
game or she does not have to gain have
game or resources also if she cheats she
will still get money from him thanks to
no fault divorce maury notice how every
man with a septum ring has terrible
takes i wonder why that is balism
imagine a guy saying that he doesn't
have a duty to protect and provide
because that would mean it's his job the
word duty may make woman upset but why
date or marry a person who doesn't
intend to take care of your needs
stephen o'brien imagine thinking that it
isn't you shouldn't care about seeing
two the things that make the other
person happy over yourself having a
servant's mindset the uk economist is
the attractive feminine lady on the sofa
single and available um trevor lane
blessed that chesca isn't on this one
matt butcher
it's not a duty for the man until she
nags disrespects and does not appreciate
you so much that you don't even want to
be around her much less have sex david
henley thank you for the super chat
monkey use up oh no bull for both teams
buckle up fella over analyzed women fall
in love wait that's from the last chat
so
the going back to the submission
topic
so a part of this interview that went
viral of this woman
was her talking about how she does
can i say this on youtube i think i can
okay i'm just gonna hope she does anal
even though she doesn't like it because
he wants it
so um the internet had a lot to say
about this part and i want to give you
guys some of the reactions from
people when they saw this so ish if you
could pull up
the next um
videos and i'll show them on my phone
okay
that's not rough
i kind of get it that's your boy
authority
men love the idea of a submissive woman
submissive per its definition is ready
to conform to the authority or will of
others
the prefix sub means under
think of subpar
submarine in short
your world is under his now there seems
to be a theme here good girls versus bad
girls a lock that can be opened with
many keys is a broken lock and if you
can't submit to a man
you're gonna die alone so my question to
men is
do you want perfect polly
a puppet
a prisoner
or a partner who has no problem overtly
challenging you
king treatment
and knowing your partner's love
languages that's one thing
being submissive is a whole another
thing it's its own thing if you find
yourself abandoning your wants needs
desires
to make something work
i'm here to tell you
it was never a match to begin with
it's painfully obvious why men love the
idea of
all the things that submission is
submission is not
doing sexual acts just to please your
man
like
i get wanting to try something that
you've never done before to see if you
like it but once you've established that
you don't like it
and he knows that
what kind of guy still wants to do it
what's attractive about doing something
with somebody that doesn't want to do it
that's not submission that's abuse
of all the things that
okay are we back
we're back
okay okay
so um i want to get your initial
reaction so we have brittany runner
who's saying
that you're basically uh
did it sound like borderline a slave to
you guys
under and then we have
the other girl who's talking about how
it's borderline abuse
what what do you guys think starting
with you um
so if you agree to it can't be abused
because you've agreed to it regardless
um
i think that
depending on your relationship and your
dynamic
it should be something that
if it's a
it's quite quite political to be honest
because some people they need those
things in their life being in submission
to a man is not abuse
in my opinion just because in your
relationship the dynamic allows that to
take place
a man's position in your relationship
allows you to be submissive
also as a woman
to reciprocate the man's position
submission is part of that and there's
nothing wrong with it for me
what bothers me is there's a problem
with saying it like what is wrong with
being submissive
there's a time and a place to be
submissive and i think because it's in a
public arena it becomes
a nitpicky
process
and i i it's like why is this even a
discussion it's very
personal
quite private
um in regards to the young lady saying i
saw the clip about the anal thing and
for me it was the lack of understanding
of basic biology that got me with her
and just because of that i switched off
so i just was like yeah
it's for whoever what do you think i'll
say originally either brittany renner
whatever her name was she went from two
extremes really she said that you don't
want a perfect polly and then she also
said on top of that someone who overtly
challenges you which are too extreme
he's like what we don't want either one
of those anyway so the fact of the
matter is a woman can be submissive a
man can be the leader he can consult
with his lady about a subject and by the
end of the day he and she know that he's
got the final say so he would take on
people's evidence and information to
make him help make a better decision so
in that case i like what you said i'm
going to add that to my thoughts and i'm
going to make the decision and she's
happy with the fact that he's used her
information as well so it's not that
extremity of perfect poly or
overtly sort of confronted or whatever
she said and then in terms of like the
anu and all that some people like that
i'm not really down with that but i
don't have anything against anyone doing
what they want to do but in a sexual
sort of engagement with your partner you
have to be willing to try and satisfy
them right i mean you learn to grow
together and synergistically as i say i
like that word because when two people
come together they have that sort of
blending of energies and understanding
of each other and the better that is the
better the sex is some people might be
yeah i like this something like that but
i could never see it as some form of
abuse imagine if a girl doesn't want to
give you head wrap she's like i don't
give head or whatever other term you
want to use for that sexual act and then
like you want it and she's saying it's
abuse because she has to do it she
doesn't have to do it number one so it
can't be abuse but like would it be a
form of um
like withholding from the man anyway and
in that case they could have negative
effects on your relationship so i think
they have to come to some sort of
agreement sexually some sort of balance
and synergy between the two people and
it's no form of abuse if you've accepted
and got down with the deed anyway
i think in the first video what i
realized is that
she made
um being submissive seem as if that the
woman had to
completely dislike everything in order
to please her man and that's what made
it submissive i feel like there's that
mis like understanding of a woman needs
to give up so much that she desires and
she wants and da da da da in order to
submit to her man no to submit to your
man or vice versa is just to want to put
this love and energy in to please your
your partner that doesn't mean it has to
take from your own cup and i think
that's a big misunderstanding that we
have nowadays
and when it comes to the second clip i
just i agree with everything you said
and i feel like that just nipped it in
the bud for me
okay for me for the first video i think
the
lady kind of confused the word
submissive as actually meaning slave and
the two are not the same
it doesn't they're not the same you know
i mean being submissive especially
as a quality in a woman is something you
want to do
it's nobody can come and drag you to
them and say you've got to do this and
you've got to do that women if they're
in a position where they like their man
they're comfortable with him they will
literally give themselves to a person
and that's not something you have to ask
for that's something that's innate it's
part of
an effeminate quality of a woman's
quality because you know i mean she's
met the masculine that is appealing to
her feminine nature and it the two just
complement each other naturally
and
i think she's looking at the meaning of
the word too much
it doesn't necessarily mean i mean she
was deconstructing it trying to talk
about what the
prefix is and the rest of the word and
i'm like you're doing a bit too much do
you know i mean actually understand what
the word means as it as as what it means
to be a woman rather than what it means
to be
property or owned you're not property
but you are as a woman you do have that
innate quality that men like
so just do it have you ever noticed that
the girls always have a horror story
whenever men have a standard or whenever
there's some some
basically control they have to give up
there's like for example abortion right
that goes away it's always great
what happens with grape it's always the
exception yeah and with this we're
talking about submission because in
submission you have to give up control
what happens
they think of the worst relationship
they've ever been in ever when it's on
us to pick better men and to pick men
with husband qualities we don't have to
deal with guys
that want to torture us so women should
be picky
yes they should yeah exactly i think the
part of the important part they're
missing is submission is something that
is given
in the right environment they seem to
think these extreme speakers that it's
forced upon you submission is not forced
upon you it's about being able to
understand this is a relationship this
is a commitment this is a balance of two
people who have who have had discussions
gone through things together and they
both agree that they're meeting at a
point where i'm happy to submit to you
and you're happy to lead and i think
another thing that women find hard
nowadays is saying a man is a leader
what's wrong with that why can't a man
need like yeah you are a boss a boss
lady let's say that let's say like that
you're a boss but
from my experience being a boss is being
able to understand who you are being
comfortable with who you are and then
allowing somebody else be a male or what
depending on
who you are but
but just allowing a man to come into
your life as a man and lead in the
situation
because your part to play in the
relationship is going to be the
nurturing the the foundations of support
those kind of things and i think like
younger generations find it hard to
understand because of the same concept
of equality
and you know being equal to men if you
don't allow a man to lead with purpose
your relationship will break down easily
the rules will increase because men are
not living with purpose they're not
living with direction and you're not
supporting it and you're not giving
space for yourself to surrender to the
situation you know that submission is
necessary in the relationship for it to
to thrive
so we just got a question a 50 super
chat
um so
because women in the west are having a
harder and harder time with
submission should western men just go to
foreign countries for women i'm becoming
convinced so i'm going to give my take
on this first
i think personally
a couple things if you can afford to the
average man makes forty five thousand
dollars per year i don't know if a cross
continental
move is really an option for most guys
but if you can afford to and you can go
find a submissive feminine woman
outside of the west i'd tell you to go
do it
um but the only issue we're gonna have
is the internet
is is everywhere so i think
the western mindset is kind of seeping
to all other parts of the world so it's
gonna become tougher and tougher but i
think if you can afford it go do it but
i would i would i get you but as a woman
who's been raised by foreign you know
individuals who didn't grow up here i
can say that there's
the problem is people do not see the
point in everybody having a set purpose
everyone wants to do everything and it
doesn't work like that as a woman in a
family if you are a wife
you do your wife duties
i was raised like that i understand the
benefits of my grandfather having my
grandmother by his by his side my dad
having my mom by his side right but you
can't be traditional though because
because like i'm saying over a certain
age like you really can't be say you're
traditional
because like i really feel like that's
like an under 25 and under type thing
like if if you're really traditional you
get married before the age of 25.
okay i get you but it's contextualizing
it into the current day so for me as a
woman
you know being in a relationship i have
to have my part to play but i have to
accept that the the man is the leader
and if you have a problem with having a
leader
a per you know giving a man
responsibility of that nature to make
decisions then you're you're sure but
but so i'm saying i'm saying typically
like you can go to other countries and
find younger women
that want to be wives
yeah and and they're younger than us
right they're more traditional than us
i'm saying if you could afford it why
wouldn't you tell god to do it yeah i
think most guys can't afford it and i
think the western mindset is seeping
everywhere it would depend where you go
to find a wife
depends on your culture as well some
cultures you've got a place where you
can go you've got an islamic background
or culture you might be able to go to
your ancestral homeland or even into
africa and so forth i really do across
the middle east but it's very different
and to be honest i would tell a man you
can find a traditional woman in the uk
and across europe you really can because
even london itself is so diverse there's
millions of people from all different
types of culture and some may adhere to
their culture quite severely and they
might follow those traditional rules but
if you got the money and you want to
travel and have that experience you
might have a higher percentage of
finding that woman especially out of big
major cities like if you live outside of
london you might find it hard like to
find a decent woman from a different
sort of culture than the traditional
western culture
but yeah i wouldn't tell a man not to
and if he has the sort of the mullah the
money to go and do that and bring
someone back home because more than
likely you're not going to go and live
in a third world country you're going to
bring them back here that's that's what
i would question like the logistics of
it because how well could you really get
to know her on like trips
so so to me the the logistics would be
kind of hard to iron out
because you want to vet a girl before
you marry me yeah and so but then you'd
have to pay for her to come here and
then vet her that way so that's like a
pretty it's a big where where would she
stay probably with you that's a pretty
big you can't guarantee that after you
bring her her she might not adopt
western that's what she's saying the
internet's everywhere yeah it's like
instagram's everywhere so a pretty girl
in a small village in the middle of
nowhere can still get flown out by a
rapper or an nba player or a different
country i think there's a lot of
variables that you do have to consider
like before i said you know it depends
where you're getting
going to get
you know away from because you could go
to a country and yet they're more
traditional in nature and they're much
easier to deal with or you can go to
another particular country and they're
actually just in a position where they
are so in their culture they actually
believe they have to be in a box
and the reason why
that might present an issue for me the
reason why i would say
you know if you want to go and get a
wife from abroad fair enough but why
don't you get a wife here in the world
and get somebody who is effectively a
robot
well western women are more
argumentative
that's what it is and so yeah so that's
what you get with that the critical
thinking like most most guys don't
really care
like it's just not
they don't really care but i'm saying it
kind of depends what you're looking for
it's not something i would advise and be
like go here and find a wife i would be
like oh yeah you could go to some place
i mean well i know but i would there are
places i might recommend and there's
places i absolutely would not recommend
and then there's places where i'm like
but over here you can have the value of
things like as i said you know critical
thinking that kind of
open-mindedness if you get what i mean
versus finding someone who's innately
rigid because their society was rigid
if you get what i'm saying yeah i think
those guys typically like the girls that
are a bit more bridging
what does it say it says that that she's
a quality wife to be honest because
because a quality wife is a help mate
equality a quality wife has a
is a virgin actually if we're gonna if
we're gonna
i want somebody who's not too bright do
you see what i'm saying no it's not no
not necessarily it's maybe it's okay
it's the the president's right-hand man
is are they not bright no they're
they're just good at making the
president look good i guess so and so
that's that's like what a wife's duty is
it's to make your man look good i mean
perhaps i mean you you could say and
power your man yeah but i'm not
necessarily talking about you know oh
they're not capable i'm kind of saying
what kind of person and mindset are you
trying to get because there's certain
parts where you can go you can get
someone who's more traditional and
that's just more to do with their
environment and it's innate to them and
you can go to certain parts where
it might not even be
let's say
a choice to be traditional if you get
what i'm saying it might be some culture
yeah yeah yeah and and i would argue it
really really really does depend on what
you're trying to what you're trying to
find well a wife and mother yes so so
for a while with with i would say a
healthy mindset
that you don't think that's a healthy
mindset to be a helpmate all cultures
have a healthy mindset i will 100 you
can't disrespect people's culture like
that don't say because you come from
this culture you don't have a healthy
mindset you can't really say that no
you're completely right but i will a
hundred percent say one of the things i
completely and utterly
prize over anything
is
the liberty to be able to have a choice
to experience do you see what i'm saying
and it really depends on what you're
trying to find are you trying to observe
tradition though no
not all not all
not all um and i will say this and i
don't care i mean not all traditions are
fair not all cultures are equal
right but you're assuming you know
better than the people that have put
those positions for hundreds i'm not
sure i'm not assuming no no no you just
said not all traditions are fair or
equal well one men and women are
different so we're never going to be
equal
you don't you don't know why those
traditions are there so something that
may look silly to you from the outside
looking in there's a good reason for it
and they did it for hundreds but that's
why i'm saying you might go somewhere
else and you might not go another place
or you might just stay here where we are
off the mindset where you're allowed to
have things like critical where they're
feminists bro and well i'm struggling
that's why the man's asking the question
should i go abroad feminists are not i
mean we all know what happened i said it
before like freedom has become a little
bit tyrannical pretty much because we're
in a society that facilitates their
their vengeance mindset rather than
doing things which is actually
correct healthy stable makes sense do
you see what i'm saying we live in an
age where we're just like oh no we have
to make sure we don't offend and we have
to be correct and we have to be right
all the time and they didn't have a stop
line yeah they just kept on going to the
point where it actually became
detrimental
feminism feminism has always been a
terrorist movement they were they were
even in the because it started and sent
oh my god i can't say the name but in
new york cintiq something okay don't
roast me in the chat falls in new york
and it was it was mostly men that
started it actually it was it and back
then they were planning assassinations
and bombings
so they were they were like they would
compare them to antifa
which makes sense yeah yeah so they've
always been a hate group yeah but i mean
i mean the point i'm trying to make is
there wasn't a stop line do you see what
i'm saying to the so it's kind of kind
of gone back on itself the freedoms are
actually taken away from our freedoms
and they're actually affecting the way
society is is but right so why would a
guy deal with that mindset if he doesn't
have to no i'm saying the only reason
why is because even with all these flaws
because i was i would use this i'll say
this before i move on to my final point
like part of the thing about
establishing a society with freedom is
that our freedoms are only relatively
recent
relatively recent and think about it
hundred years hundred years that's still
relatively recent in the grand scheme of
things like
means six of my lives i mean perhaps
perhaps but that's all there's something
to do with me today that is true but
that's also a society on learning
hundreds of years of a particular
practice but just a century it's not
unlearning when when when remember men
had to fight in war so you could argue
that you could argue that they were the
oppressed sex i mean you could argue
the point i'm trying to make is that
with the introduction of rights and it
being a much more recent thing say for
example women's freedoms and feminism
that's that's an example
we're in we're at a stage where
we're learning to walk before we run so
there's always going to be times when
you fall over there's going to be times
when you bust your knee there's going to
be times when you hurt yourself there's
going to be times when you get it wrong
what do you mean we're learning to walk
for what
i mean when if if we're going to
introduce things like freedoms and you
know women's rights and stuff
the journey to the place which makes
sense is going to be full of a lot of
hurdles and a lot of people doing
nonsense before we get to a place where
it makes sense do you see what i'm
saying no because i feel like we've been
running no i feel like i have i think i
mean birth control was developed in the
60s oh no absolutely so so we've had
reproductive power much more
reproductive okay let me just let me use
this as a we had that without being too
influential okay
think of it as
look at feminism okay yeah now i might
be going a little bit off tan tangent
but and maybe i might be making
connecting dots that aren't necessarily
correct but now look at things like
transgenderism okay do you see what i'm
saying
when it's kind of growing a bit out
there
was feminism with transgenderism no i
mean i mean think of it like this and i
don't know if i'm explaining it
correctly i'm maybe i'm just
overthinking this but you get what i'm
saying right
i'm not too sure where the two are tying
up you kind of get what i'm saying right
no no you have no
you haven't connected it yeah okay well
basically put it like this let's see
all the all the types of freedoms and
rights are you saying they've gone too
far basically is what you're saying yeah
but i mean let's um let's say it's now
we've now reached a stage where we're
even watering down the concept of a
woman
do you see what i'm saying and now it's
it's kind of gone so far that it's
actually contradictory to what feminism
is now you've got things right i mean
you're replicating for this society and
you've been advocating for that over the
other cultures that exist like without
these sort of factors
in africa they've been running they've
had kings and queens and women normal
anger you've had amina you've had
cleopatra you've had aisha of the
islamics yeah but what's that
because because the whole world has
women have been taking their place over
time it's only in the west where they've
been potentially restricted and now
that's been implemented and changed
throughout other cultures they've been
fully established as leaders as black
warriors as queens and that's not just
in africa it's throughout but it's not
and it's not and it's not oppression
because like we just had our roles
even when we didn't have the right to
vote we couldn't get drafted so
i would argue i would argue i would
argue i would argue that like honestly i
don't know what we were fighting for now
i don't know what we were fighting for
after we got the right to vote and most
women didn't even want that i mean
perhaps but i mean that would have just
been for this society but then you have
to ask was that appropriate or correct
like you could go to vote no i'm saying
you might want to return
i might wanna i might wanna return it
guys
that sounds like you would give it up if
you have to go to war tomorrow you'll be
giving up that video that's what i'm
saying if i if i have i mean
guys one at a time i'm talking one at a
time i'm talking okay if i had to go to
war tomorrow and it was
it and it was at the cost of being being
able to vote i would give up the right
to vote easy i don't know i'm not sure
y'all trying to go on the battlefield
i'm not oh absolutely i'll be i'll be on
the floor in the kitchen
absolutely but that's only because
that's a problem which this society
created in terms of they tied being able
to vote to having to get drafted in the
war the two of those things didn't have
to be connected that's a that's a here
thing that could be well it used to be
it used to be with owning property yeah
that was poor so you you couldn't vote
unless you owned property because they
wanted it was it informed populace yeah
i mean i'm not completely 100 familiar
with the history of that but the point
i'm trying to make is that's a sort of
engineered problem if you get what i'm
saying the two of those things didn't
have to be connected but you could go to
any other society at that time maybe
i don't know okay maybe not specifically
at that time because there was a lot of
stuff going on in the world but any
other age and yes you did have places
where women could vote you as you said
women were in positions of power women
were in positions of you know x y and z
but we now live in an age where despite
the flaws of the west we do live in a
place which encourages things like as i
said critical thin thinking or freedom
of to be freedom of you know x y and z
it might be that this current social
consciousness is going in a correct in
in an incorrect way or in a way that
kind of creates problems but that is a
value which i don't think should be
given up for anything because that
mindset that freedom to you know
actually of thought to be to experience
to be able to you know
change things up it's what makes you
think that value isn't there
just perceived and
allocated differently
how do you mean like in other cultures
yeah i think it's quite i think it's
demonstration so can i have an example
of what culture specifically you're
talking about that doesn't have those
values i mean because i think it's easy
to say oh not in the west but if we're
not talking about a specific culture
okay i mean let me
give you an example of let's say a i
don't know what culture because because
often after that i've always heard sorry
i'm sorry go go ahead i've always heard
and maybe i'm just incorrectly informed
but i have a friend who's actually
living at the moment like let's say a
country like thailand thailand okay
maybe not the best example in the world
but there you could go there and you can
find women who are much more let's say
traditional in there but in their um how
they are in society and you know my
friends has explained to me oh yeah
they're all nice they're all you know
really beautiful here they're all very
you know kind of more traditionalist in
their views now that's not me saying oh
that's all that thailand consists of but
he's kind of maybe i'm getting it wrong
but he's giving me the impression that
that's kind of how this society is but
you don't think those women
can freely think you don't think no i
was in thailand oh
what i'm talking about is thailand's
social consciousness their society their
society there are women there who are
much more traditional and that's why i'm
saying there could be some places where
you can go to get much more traditional
one
but yeah but they can't freely think no
they can that's what i'm i'm just
quoting back what you're saying saying
thai women can't freeze because i feel
like you're kind of going in circles no
no i'm not and you're saying
i'm not saying thai women can't freely
think i'm just giving you an example of
when i was saying there's places where
you could go right and so when i said
okay what place then you said thailand
and then i'm saying in thailand and you
said the cost at some of those places
where the girls are more traditional is
that they can't freeze what i'm saying
so now that now that we have that you
couldn't really think we could roll back
traditionally we could roll back okay
yeah i mean okay far enough if i got it
wrong then maybe i miss explain myself
okay but the point i was trying to make
is they're much more from what i've
heard traditional in in the terms of you
know how they carry themselves in
society they're much more traditionalist
they you know tend to
be you know if you know much more say
like homekeeping roles and stuff and i'm
i'm not i've never been to thailand i'm
just saying what i've been told of there
but that would give me let's say an
example of if someone was like oh i'm
gonna go and get a wife from a foreign
country and i can be like yeah thailand
would be all right i mean why not you've
got women who are much more
traditionalists but they also have
more sort of like
freedom and autonomy over themselves do
you know what i'm saying so now my
second they have the freedom and
autonomy over themselves
but so because the social consciousness
is different where you know that
generally speaking from what i've heard
i might be mistaken i might be mistaken
maybe it's not the best example but from
what i've heard they're much more
traditional in how they do things just
as in the what women do and what men do
they are that's what i've heard so it
might be mistaken i just
i just feel like you said a lot enough
yeah it's going wrong because no because
because i i'm like
no but you'll do you no no no let me
i've you've been going so so i'm saying
earlier when i asked you why wouldn't
they want to get a wife from there
you were talking about there's some
issue with the free thinking right or
something something so long maybe that's
a little off but something along the
lines of like in a more traditional
culture no there's a lack of yeah i
think i get weather yeah and so i was
trying to explain to you firstly what
might be an example of what i meant when
i say oh you can go to another country
and get yeah you know a more um let's
say traditional
um
wife and she's much more in a
traditional role but i was trying to
give an example of someone where she can
be traditional whilst having the same
value of things like freedom of thought
freedom to be not in a position where
like you're coerced to be uh-huh well
she was asking you for the bad culture
yeah like i asked you
a culture that like you thought the
women didn't have the oh i would say
saudi arabia saudi arabia yeah so you
think is an example there's no like
there's a like for example just what i'm
saying but i'm saying you don't know
you're wrong correct me from what i'm
saying you don't know that culture and
so like like like a joke a joke i make
often is like saudi arabia like the
women didn't have the right to drive for
a while and i'm like yeah if i could get
driven around all the time
do i want the right to drive i mean
you're right you could say but but what
i'm what i'm saying is like you you
can't know what the women want in that
culture like if you don't know them
you've never talked to you all right so
so like the men are saying where can we
find these traditional wives they're not
in the west so like why wouldn't you
encourage someone to go to where the
traditional that's why i was saying
before do you want to marry someone
who's a traditionalist or they're saying
someone who's confined to a box no no i
think they prefer the traditionalist
that's what i'm saying that's why i was
saying i'm might be mistaken yeah but i
would recommend oh go somewhere like
time but that's only your interpretation
and and the other thing well and let's
put data behind this right like in the
in the west where where women are the
most like free thinking they're the
least happy and one way that they
measure this is the women are on more
antidepressants than anywhere else in
the world
and women the least happy demographic of
women is single childless and make over
50 dollars per year yeah so it's like
that's so so that's true so so i'm
saying like we we could judge those
cultures and say maybe they don't have a
choice but maybe women but maybe
okay i need you to let me finish this is
my show so all right so so i'm saying
when you're in those cultures
like you don't know you can't say those
women aren't happy some women it's like
you too much choice ruins us
but you could say that about everyone
it's true the psychology of choice
you're like
less happy with your choices but like
another example is body count a lot of
times in non-western cultures women's
body count are lower so for example if a
woman has sex with one person she's a
virgin on her wedding night she has an
80 chance of being in a happy marriage
in 10 years on the other hand if she
slept with five or more people which
honestly based on the guys that i talked
to on this show they're praying their
girl has five or less bodies
they're like they're like they're like
that's amazing but even
but even five or less that that's a 25
chance of a happy marriage so it goes
from 80 to 25
by sleeping with five or more people and
so when when the guys are thinking do i
want to western women who the average
age of first marriage in the uk is 31
how many bodies is she going to have by
31.
so so average age of first marriage in
the us is 27 almost 28. so how many how
many bodies is she gonna have by that
like like the this choice and empowering
women doesn't leave us happy
and so that's why that's why men want to
avoid western women i mean but you don't
have to agree but i'm saying like they
they survey women yeah they're not as
happy
just to add feminism feminism in my
opinion destabilizes women simple as
it's that straightforward and for me as
a woman
a lot of feminists that i see their
points are not even about oh i am
is it off okay
so
um
for me when i hear feminists speak
they're not actually speaking about
women's empowerment they're talking
about men so much that they're they're
not even on point with what they're
trying their message they think they're
trying to send
and for me that shows me that feminism
is is something that shouldn't be
even in society they don't even need to
exist and to be honest let's be real and
they got all the rights they need now
it's illegal to pay people less and all
this sort of thing so i was going to say
as well with like the pay okay to say
with the pay gap now there is no pay gap
there is literally no paid up when you
look at the stats for what they are
looking at
and it's illegal to pay someone on a
sexual discrimination basis
and there's quotas too for specifically
to hire women
like it's in their favor yeah yeah so
i'm like i'm sorry if you can't if you
can't get a job
that's on you yeah that's on you
come to the point of feminism for me
feminism destabilizes women it
destabilizes them in such a way where
they are not able to fulfill their own
desires even the ones in their feminine
idea ideology they can't they can't
reach those pinnacles because it's not
even realistic
they focus so much on
men
that it's like do you like men or not i
have to ask feminists when i hear them
speak i'm like so do you like me
i don't think
is counterintuitive to their their
mission
yeah so looking at
a traditional wife um
and the feminist ideals that men are you
know basically useless so why is it that
everything that men do in a traditional
role as a provider you're trying to do
it doesn't make sense well that's what
they say like women become the men they
want to marry
my point is they fail to do that even if
they try to do it they fail because
they're not designed to do that they
don't actually
no and i know someone's going to send
for me they don't have the faculties to
do so because they're a woman and
there's nothing wrong with that as a
woman you have
attributes that men do not have and when
you try to assign feminine attributes to
a man you emasculate him you destroy a
relationship as a feminist because let's
be real a lot of feminists have children
so how did you end up with a man
yeah your id your ideology
ideology outwardly is men are trash and
anything men can do i can do but you're
still in a family unit you still want
traditional um
traditional
provisions from a man in in your
relationship but you don't respect men
you want a traditional man when they're
not traditional women there's a lot of
fake feminists even cardi b she's a fake
feminist she's rapping about all this
stuff but really when you get home she's
actually cooking cleaning and doing what
the hell
tells her to do like this yeah but she
ain't traditional though no i'm saying
she's a fake feminist is what i said
yeah so she would talk about i don't
cook i don't clean and women power boss
[ __ ] this sort of language but then
she's at home mopping up and doing
whatever he says and taking him back if
he cheats and so forth right and the
same as like all my women are
independent bloody daddy beyonce it's
the same thing that was a sort of
feminist sort of song and i was to the
left hold up all this stuff in a box to
the left that song as well these sort of
man-bashing songs but when you check it
out they're not bashing their man
they're taking whatever he says and
doing it well and and that's the thing
modern women are side chicks and that's
that's the thing most feminists you know
they're side chicks because again if you
ask a hundred percent of women who they
want they want twenty percent of men you
you want a guy that's over six foot
that's fifteen percent of guys you want
a guy that makes over 70k per year i
don't know that stat but
but i i think it's like 20 30 percent of
guys so on top of that you want them to
be attractive it's a smaller and smaller
and smaller percentage and the problem
is before women used to prioritize the
the character of a man over the way he
looked and and his providing skills but
then when the development of birth
control happened women had the option to
sleep with whoever
and then try as a mating strategy
they'll maybe get a kid from the first
guy that had the genes they wanted and
marry the second guy that had the
providing provision
so that's why you hear girls say oh i
need to have my whole face they want to
succeed because they yeah the like ho
phase because you know they they wanted
to get
the the alpha guys out of there out of
their system but the problem is once
you've had too many alpha guys you can't
go back and you're never going to be
satisfied in your marriage you get an
alpha widow term and i said that six six
six is six four six pack and six figures
and they end up not being that guy and
as you say you have so many of these
chad guys the giga jack chad's or
whatever they call them on the net or a
masculine men that are out here getting
all the girls and then they end up being
alpha widows because when they ain't
gonna have a guy that can deal with them
like that guy dealt with them that's why
the women always go back here to the man
that beat it up the best unfortunately
that's like a known thing women talk
amongst each other about that guy he did
it like this and he's the man and this
and that and it's quite an important
factor to these so-called alpha widows
because if the next man is not
sufficient in that particular area in
terms of the you know
sex and then they're gonna be suffering
i have a story on this i always say
girls always have that one x they can't
get over and that you'll see a girl
she's dating the next guy right but
she's thinking about the last guy she's
not over it doesn't matter like you know
that she would go back at his beck and
call so i put this on my story because
well someone else did i shared it and
this girl responds to me and she says
not always it took me 10 years to
realize i was delusional i go to her
profile she's married with like kids
and i'm like does your husband know
that whole
thing
that whole mindset comes from low
self-esteem so a lot of sorry a lot of
women they lead with their sexuality but
they don't have the confidence
in themselves they don't have that
confidence so when they're pursued but
say for example they see a guy he's
trash basically he he doesn't have money
he can give no no he's trash in the
sense that we can give his sex basically
he has no money he hasn't got legit
leadership skills another man in their
life down the line has leadership skills
he has a decent amount of money his sex
is uh
then they still go back to the the broke
guy because of the sex what alongside a
lot of other women who might be seeing
that man um it's about low self
low self-esteem as a woman
i think that when it comes to your
sexuality when you give it to when you
give that away to a man
in a way that's
if you say the whole phase
you're opening yourself up emotionally
you're opening yours you're feeling
you're
spreading yourself so thinly that you
actually don't realize
that you don't know what you want you
don't know
no i i don't think it's low self-esteem
i think it's if anything high
self-esteem it's girls batting out of
their league exactly yeah and so and so
that's that's what i think i think it's
girls typically
when when they're because guys will have
sex with anything so it'll be like a
girl four five six sleeping with an
eight nine or ten right maybe looks wise
might be sex wise so so she thinks she's
on that level and then she'll go to the
next guy and leave him and go back to
the old guy yeah but that's what i'm
saying so to me that comes across as low
self-esteem because really her whole
thing the premise of her whole position
is based on that man's looks alone
whereas if you're dealing with a real
man in my opinion not not always a man
that has faculties about him financially
stable he's solving et cetera et cetera
but it's not related to the man it's
related to herself she's like i'm so
good i can get attention she thinks i
can get a chat i can get a six foot
figures no woman is leaving if she
doesn't think she could do better
exactly like i had a girl it's about her
self-esteem
i mean when you say that about everyone
yeah yeah yeah i agree but women are the
one leaving
that's true yeah so it's like
that's a man sleeps with them because
it's easy
sex basically because say he's deemed as
a eight or a nine or a ten and then a
five or six is like she fancies the hell
out of this guy she's letting it off
relatively freely because i said that
carnal urge is ridiculous
he beats it up and deals with it
appropriately as he should and then when
he's like you're just a five or six year
later she goes back to her boyfriend and
finds another guy on her level but she's
always craving for that guy and believes
she's capable of obtaining that type of
man but really all she was was an easy
easy
don't face reality men do because every
bad choice women always coddle each
other so for example we have body
positivity
instead instead of saying lose weight
get on the treadmill if you want that
guy that's offensive like that's not
offensive no i know but that's in
i agree i don't think it's actually
offensive but in this society it is body
shaming and they call it right or or
there's like there's beauty stan like
unrealistic beauty standards it's like
no it's not unrealistic you just don't
fit it no but i don't think there's
anything wrong with having a beauty
standard every i mean there's an ideal
right why what's nothing wrong with that
i think
i think they've just created a society
that just kind of panders we could we
could have lizzo go on a public platform
shooter shout out shooter shot at chris
hemsworth
and and everyone will cheer her on you
go girl you go sis and if a guy did that
if a fat short broke i did that with a
victoria's secret super bottle everyone
would be like laughing at it
yeah but that's what i'm saying like
women don't face reality men men do and
so that's why women are much more
delusional than men
yeah they're not looking but i feel
required to and that's the uh that's the
key thing we're not required to uh
political correctness one mad exactly
the political correct
aspect favors women's delusions and the
problem with that is we don't not all
the women in this room but we don't
realize that we're depleting depleting
ourselves by doing that we're depleting
our qualities and depleting our position
by doing that um
i don't think there's anything wrong
with having an ideal i don't think
there's anything wrong with portraying
you know women as you know slim and
there's nothing wrong with that i think
it only becomes uh i think society has
just made it an issue as if to say oh no
you have to be um if if you don't like
this woman who is like
i don't know 600 pounds and then you're
not being fair and it's like well i'm
not trying to be funny but part of
sexuality is you have to discriminate
you have to have a type otherwise you're
just sleeping with anyone
yes or no
exactly but you don't accept it in this
society and you will get called out for
being a misogynist a fat shamer or if
people don't like particular races she'd
be called a colorist it could be called
anything to shame a man's preferences
but a woman can come out here like lizzo
and say he's got a short dick or small
dick no no one will say anything the
misandry they can be heightest and say
he's if he's not over this high i'm not
going to deal with him and they can even
shame your income so if you're incoming
to that level i don't want no scraps
so these things is like it's not equal
in that terms again but if a guy said i
don't want no whales will
[Laughter]
if she's over 50 over 250 leave her ass
like
and then but they'll have rap lyrics
about if if he's broke leave him yeah
i know it's double standard it is a
double standard i'm going to take a
second to read super chats real quick
and then we'll probably wrap up the show
um this was a very fun conversation
thank you guys so much for the super
chats as you guys know all these
donations are going towards getting ish
a camera
get-ish a
camera let's go reveal that guy's face
has no one seen what you look like yeah
no they have no no no no no
they have never seen it let me let me
know what you think she looks like in
the chat
lucas um lucas with the 50 super chat
let's go
six six four tech executive single dad
no prospects that's what i'm looking
abroad look i live in england i'm abroad
um okay senoras diets feminists at the
table ladies choose to sit at it mgtow
by logic no women became the truth tr
women became the trash version of the
men they wanted to be with because of
that they're broken and they have a
trash image of a man
chris mccartney
dude don't listen
dude doesn't listen the point i'm trying
to make over and over and over operative
word trying add uh so many words without
saying anything adonis 1909 this guy is
a tool he's borderline confused by
himself that's why he cannot stick to
something he doesn't know what he wants
god in c i smell betta and thailand is
great 90 free tope
bro is throwing a board salad tmac one
1979 dude with nose rings are clearly
confused super happy that jessica isn't
there that would be unbearable um 90
free toe pay pearl is the baddie in
black single
are you single
she's taken
oh you're in black too are you single
are you single she's single yeah she is
i was like
one of the buddies
yeah i was like are they both in black
okay
december um zero eight one men have
inverted and will perfect
perfect robot women and are more and
more incentivized to speed up the
process is if women don't change they
will be alone um das token
a septum ring just has a lesser
knowledge of self dash token curious
does septum rings speak another language
lord commander if you be if you two if
you need to be making at least 100k to
date abroad effectively you aren't going
to get anything but hood chicks that
look good
they don't want to come live in your one
bedroom 700 apartment you need to be
ballin
okay for a hunter um definition of
submission noun one the action or fact
of accepting or yielding to a superior
force or to the will of or authority of
another person das token western xx are
too much imagine going to work slaving
all day and bringing home the bacon and
you're
and you're signif what does xx mean is
that like significant other or your
girlfriend i don't know equates um being
at home to slavery goofy af 90 free
topay females should not be should be
picky but not unrealistic any male who
laughs after making a point is sad
jbhr so somebody is gonna so somebody
gonna play us a song with that guitar or
what um david david henley the creator
of sex in the city said she regrets
prioritizing having a career over having
kids and that now she is truly alone
oh that's that could be a show i'm gonna
write that down panels thoughts
billy boy i hate shopping i do it with
my wife for my wife um das token just
because you can doesn't mean you should
just because
i'm guessing xx your girlfriend can have
sex with anyone she can also get stds
and stis from doing just about anyone
goofy af jake bannon men don't have the
right to vote we pay for it with the
draft registry in force 191a one way or
the other free riding the vote should
shielded consequences
shed lid you have great legs
lucas
oh wait i read this one already trevor
lane lady to the right's voice is that
deep she can talk to these feminist
whales
stephen o'brien the government gets a
cut of child support oh that's that's
the end let me refresh it real quick um
well at the end so
why don't we go around everyone say any
final thoughts you have and tell the
people where they can find you starting
with you um so my thoughts are
traditionalism is not dead
it is very workable
and yeah keep doing what you're doing
i'm in the mic i'm in a minute my lips
are touching it
but um
yeah
you done it yeah yeah i would say um a
lot of it was about submission today so
i would say women if you're out there
and you have what you believe is a good
man just bloody submit to that man
because it will help you in your
relationship and probably make it be a
long-term productive relationship in
terms of some other things i was going
to say i had one saying about like a
woman trying to keep up or trying to
keep pace with a strong masculine man
just makes her a weak woman and a man
trying to keep up or match a strong
woman in their feminine energy makes him
a weak man so really what we got to do
is hold our own stances our own
positions and synergize those together
and that's when you get the piece the
yin and the yang forms the whole circle
and that's how you get that productive
positive relationship so hold your role
women submit men lead men up your game
we know we need that six pack we do we
can get it we can get more money if you
if you're not tall enough i don't know
wear some shoes with hills and those bro
and other than that you can find me on
instagram at um ipsy b i b z ibzyyb
and i also have another instagram
channel which is at the masculine
advocate so you can get me on there
where i'm sort of advocating positive
masculine energy
and all different walks of life and i've
been considering doing a podcast and
i've got all the cameras and stuff at
home because i'll do a lot of media
stuff outside of it so maybe one day
you'll see me maybe working with the
lovely pearl or some of these other
podcasts out here so yeah respect to the
chat they didn't get at me or nothing
like that so big you guys up
i would say to conclude i feel like
the west in particular definitely needs
to reevaluate their roles within
themselves within society i feel like we
need to hone in and really rebalance and
center on who we are because that will
allow
for our generations to be a bit more
clear within the relationships um i
think it's really important that people
understand that submission isn't
necessarily
you filling someone else's cup and not
yours you can do both especially as a
woman you know nurturing is very key i'm
gonna always like reinforce that we
nurture not just one thing but we
nurture everything a woman is the
backbone of her family so we can carry
our whole family behind us
the man is the provider he is the
protector that is a very big thing and
we
need to
learn to just chill out and not take
everything so
personal and be more willing to accept
traditional roles
that allocate to you um
i've been miriam i also have a podcast
it's called conscious conversations on
youtube you can find it on spotify and
apple music check it out i appreciate
everybody i love this experience i feel
like my biggest the reason why i started
my podcast and go on everybody a lot of
other people's platforms is because i
intend to be educated as well as eduk
and i feel like this platform has
provided a lot of information education
for me so i'm very grateful for that i'm
grateful for everybody the people that
came at me the people that didn't that
showed me love i love all of you man
honestly i love this type of interaction
so thank you for having me on um
official miriam on instagram c dot
conversations podcast on instagram and
just conscious conversations on youtube
and spotify yeah and i'll probably come
on right soon yeah yeah guys
at her tell us to come unconscious
conversations
all right and to close i think i'm just
going to say um
you know when it comes to
relationships i would say men women try
to get along you know especially um as
it pertains to a woman's role and a
mandrel speak to each other communicate
know that you're on the same page so
your relationship is a collaborative
effort make sure that you you have the
same values and you have the same goals
as long as you can say that the two of
you are trying to achieve the same thing
and you're trying to you know hold each
other up your relationship will work
just make sure that you understand it's
a commitment you're in for the long run
and i think i would finally
add that traditionalism there is nothing
wrong with traditionalism in fact i
would say it serves as the ideal sort of
blueprint for what has a you know
constitute a successful household
raising successful kids
but um at the same time also be open to
the fact that we are in a modern age try
and do things in a different way in a
new way if you have to and be open to
the eye to you know to the facts that
your relationship can adapt to the times
just just make sure that every party
that's participating
is um is is agreeable on whatever you're
all doing that's it okay i'm done
so um we also got one more super chat
get-ish a camera from lucas let's go
lucas i appreciate you okay guys make
sure you like the video on your way out
it really helps with the algorithm um
that's how youtube's first metric and
when they put what content they push out
on top of that follow our new facebook
page and our new twitch page follow my
instagram just.purlythings if you want
to get on the show message eddie his
link is in the description he's our new
recruiter don't forget to subscribe to
the channel ring that notification bell
sign up for our memberships to be a part
of the chat next stream and we will talk
to you next time